êtes vous plutôt bd franco-belge manga
ou comics des styles littéraires
différents qui alimente les discussions
entre lecteurs et bibliothécaires
notamment lors de ce café comics
organisée à la médiathèque jean
rousselot de guyancourt des moments des
changes pour découvrir de nouveaux
ouvrages
je me semble peut-être plus plus à
l'aise avec le format de la bd j'avoue
que le manga je ne suis pas je ne suis
pas vraiment très spécial et je m'engage
je regarde je regarde je me balade aussi
dans les rayons manga mais j'avoue que
je suis tout petit peu moins tiré par
immédiatement attiré par le manga que
par la bd je dis pas mal de bd mais plus
spécifiquement manga donc c'est plus ce
style là qui moi matière personnellement
alors mon gars très peu jean denis
lucquin j'ai vu death note et par excès
quand même fondamental mais
mais sinon je dis un peu de bd un peu de
comics web mais pas énormément plusieurs
comics bd et mangas sont présentés aux
lecteurs des livres envoyés par les
librairies aux médiathèques pour les
faire découvrir aux adhérents et
recueillir leurs avis un public assez
ouvert concernant le monde de la bd
et bien en fait on a un public assez
éclectique donc du coup on a des fans de
mangas des fans de comics un peu de fans
de bd et puis après on a des gens qui
aiment un petit peu tous qu'ils sont
suffisamment curieux pour taper dans les
trois domaines
un clivage qui tend à s'effacer
plusieurs dessinateurs ont déjà
conjuguer les trois styles dans
plusieurs ouvrages